what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Spring Water I have the pleasure of
chatting with some of the team behind
the movie Ry Lane congratulations feels
like a like a one-of-a-kind style tone
comedy drama mashup that comes together
like better than I ever could have
imagined had you given me just the
script in the script alone oh thank you
I'm very thank you so much I actually
shouldn't say that and I'll I'll pose
that question to you first before we
even jump into a synopsis but how much
can you feel what this tone what the
tone of the film is supposed to you know
look and feel like just based on like
black and white text on a page I think
because we know South London you
understand the heart of it so even
though it might not be like apparent to
someone that doesn't get the like
references and the nuances but to us
like seeing it on the page and then like
understanding like rain rain is like an
altar and like her perspective on
filmmaking you immediately can sort of
get a feel for what it would be like
yeah
well could you would you mind asking the
question again yeah just the idea of
having a having a movie that has such a
specific and unique feel to it that
feels to me at least from my limited
perspective like it only really comes to
life with your cast your edit the energy
the colors on set if you're able to
actually see that when you're just
reading the words on the page
um really good question uh
uh I think I mean I guess I'll answer it
by saying that
um when I got the script it definitely
felt like there was space to elevate it
and bring my kind of World building to
the whole thing
um so I would say that you know the
script is so funny
and that you know it's it's so funny but
it's also really simple and I think that
gives you the opportunity to
um go kind of wild with the craft you
know and that's a huge part of what I do
every little thing every little detail
and I can talk about the X because
that's a whole other kind of element but
World building is like my favorite thing
to do and when you
every little piece of what I make is
kind of connected you know from the
costume to the to the color grade to the
edit to the hair and makeup
um but then you put really good actors
in who totally understand the story and
totally understand the characters and
have their own unique way of
showing these people that are just so
representative of like London now
um so yeah maybe I didn't answer that
question exactly but I guess I kind of
explained that what you know from script
to making it that that process that's
the kind of the process for me I've got
an ingredient I've already started
talking details about your movie our
audience might not know what rylene is
about just yet so rain I'll give these
duties to you can you give a brief
description of what the movie is yeah
um it's so funny we keep giggling about
it because we're like so many people are
going to ask us what it's about and
we're like how do you but it's a very
simple you know it's it's two people
that meet kind of at the wrong time but
they're pretty perfect for each other
and they have a really fun day in South
London okay now I can go back to
specifics you just brought up the idea
of it feeling like the script had room
for you to evolve it I guess what is it
like seeing room for a script to grow
and not interpreting that as a negative
thing versus a positive not not feeling
like it's already full and that gives me
confidence
um well I think I guess there's a huge
development people don't really talk
much about development and it's so key I
mean we developed the script for like a
year and a half
um I think it was a year and a half
something like that
um and
I guess I never look at anything as
finished until I'm like making it and it
in a way it's weird now because it's
like it is finished and I can't do
anything I can't change any little thing
um but yeah the script
it's always a process I think it's
always developing and you know working
with Vivian David was great because for
me I want to work with actors and I want
them to say I would never that that
character I don't think they would ever
say that you know so it's never fit it's
never kind of finished black and white
in my opinion and it's never finished
from the audience perspective too
because now you're giving your baby out
to the world and everyone will have
their different interpretation and it'll
keep the conversation alive I love it
yeah for my stars here what is something
about your character that you are most
eager to play when you first book the
role but then what is something you
discovered during the filmmaking process
that was more fulfilling than you ever
could have imagined
pressure's on
what was interesting about Dom
um I guess I guess I don't know I guess
I'm always drawn to like characters who
aren't uh
your regular
guy or young black man
um so don was even though I recognized
him being from South London supports
Crystal Palace I don't support Crystal
Palace but he's a football guy
um you know I mean like I recognize all
that in him but he's also like very
strange like you know he gets it wrong
quite a lot of the time like
um and I like that because it meant that
um he doesn't think the same way I do so
I mean I had to like
I think I got maybe a bit more game than
him
absolutely thank you just waiting for
you say that rain
but you know um but something else I
found interesting when I was finding him
with rain actually is you know I didn't
need to do so much sometimes like Reigns
a master in my opinion at stripping
things back
even though it's like a romantic comedy
and there's so many layers to it rain's
just amazing at going oh like you can
just like you can just be there and that
was really that was really awesome yeah
um
um for me I think
I personally would like to think I'm a
very rational person in like my personal
life Yaz is like entirely impulse like
and entirely like devoted to living in
fantasy of her own design and I was just
really excited to like
be occupied like a character who just
she's kind of like a whirlwind and like
she spins through everyone's life and
she would just keep on keep on keep on
spinning and she'll pick you up and
she'll spit you out if you don't agree
with her fantasy and I think that
Devotion to like
yeah that and like escapism I was like
this is really really fun
um I think yeah again I would say as
well what I discovered in like the
playing of it is like just not thinking
too much and just being and again that's
like credit to rain like in all the kind
of
mumbly like messiness that come out like
that would come out like very naturally
like in speech like that's all adding to
the character stuff that you kind of be
like oh like I maybe shouldn't have
said it like that or was that even
audible like like stuff like that was
like the flavor and like the seasoning
which added to her
um yeah
it was raw ooh many follow-up questions
you use the word impulsive when you're
playing a character who's so impulsive
do you have to have like an anchor or a
Guiding Light so that no matter what
decision she makes it's always based in
some sort of consistent truth
um I think uh the consistent truth that
I found with Yaz is that she just has an
endless curiosity for the world and so
if someone's doing something it's like
why are they doing that she's going to
constantly like challenge people she's
going to constantly push boundaries
because and it's not because she's like
an antagonist it's literally just
curiosity obviously that pushes too far
shouldn't believe that she shouldn't be
able to do anything because to her she
can justify anything but that was kind
of like yeah but grounding it in like a
curiosity as opposed to like something
else was a way to stay kind of honest to
also like there's like a childishness
about her which I think kids are quite
curious as well so yeah that helped me
ground it for sure so we've gotten your
perspectives on what came out of your
characters along the way rain I'm
curious For You especially because you
brought up how much you developed the
script is there anything that they
brought out of their characters or their
story on set that made even you go I
didn't realize this element of our
material was as strong as it is
I think they brought everything to it
you know I think um
that's you know it's almost like in a
way you if you cast a really good eyes
you don't really need to direct them
that much it's kind of lazy uh no but I
um I mean they brought everything to it
I couldn't have imagined it being
yeah I I
can't yeah I think
watching them I mean cutting these suits
was hilarious
um but um
I think that the actors just
I like building worlds and I love
finding people that can just bring
something to that I would never bring to
it I think as a director your job is
essentially surrounding yourself with
people that are better at things than
you
you know that is the job so when you get
really amazing actors it's a joy and
it's kind of like oh whoa it's
everything
so yeah perhaps better at specific
things than you but if you're not the
best possible leader you can be then all
of their work goes to waste because you
have to bring it together yeah but I I
am really good at bringing things
together but I but they are I could
never
I could never Act
I very much understand that's why I sit
here and admire
um I was reading a little bit in the
production notes about the significant
amount of people on this production both
in front of and behind the lens who are
making their first feature why was that
appealing to you rather than it feeling
like a risk for someone to have a first
on your feature film
I think
um I think when you think about I mean I
definitely feel that
my favorite
creators rather than directors I think
creators always have their own worlds
and
that's that's done by working with
people that are unique and haven't you
know that have kind of got a slightly
different take on things so I never
really I was never that bothered about
working with anyone that you know had
got masses of experience
specifically in
um in feature films a lot of the crew
came from commercials music videos
shorts they're people that I've worked
with all the time they know exactly what
I like they know what I don't like they
know when I'm being a bit weird that it
just means that I'm panicking and they
need to reassure me rather than you know
there's like a real shorthand there
which is amazing
and it was a joy to make to have that
thing where it's all our first feature
together it was it was unique sincerely
but one of my favorite things to learn
about is a director's monitor dance like
when what signals to you too that rain
feels like you've nailed a take and you
can move on rain
rain don't act rain doesn't actually
even have signals rain will just be like
great yeah
yeah great great great great oh no do I
really say that she's got the best
mankunian voice as well so you just once
you hear that boom across the morning
all right let's move on well also
because we were shooting during covid
and like my eyebrows are quite worried
so they kept looking I had this mask on
and they kept looking at me and David
would always go are you okay
and then I'd have to go it was really
great
I I struggle with uh trying to pull
positives out of the pandemic but
sometimes I find that when you're used
to working a certain way and those
things are Stripped Away you realize
that there are other corners of your
craft that are valuable that you never
would have had access to had you had
your user your usual way of working an
assortment of tools so going through
this process is there anything new each
of you discovered about your craft for
that reason
oh like like massively you know um
probably goes without saying like I'm so
grateful to Reign for for having me I'm
sure people say the same in this film
because
this is this is my first feature film I
still feel like incredibly inexperienced
in everything like life
um so to be in in this film and
obviously for it and I come to sign
dance number one is crazy but number two
like
I was able and it's every job that I get
now it feels that way I was able to like
learn so much about myself and how to
navigate
even just set you know like I'm I'm you
know I like to think I'm good at like
maybe tackling the mental of a character
but then you have to deal with like some
boom like dangling in front of your face
here and and all these kind of things so
rain given us the opportunity to do that
it was everything so I can't even
pinpoint one thing it was like
everything
yeah I think for me I just believe
creatively across the board limitations
are really important I think they birth
like the most interesting work like if
you have to find a workaround for
something
um and yeah so covert was like the
maddest limitation
um I think the isolation and
the subsequent insanity but it was like
in my mind from being isolated for so
long really helped me
to create the fantasy world that Yaz
wants to occupy because I think we spent
the whole the like the previous two
years before I did the job I was just
imagining being outside imagining having
fun like imagining seeing my friends and
then like
stepping into a character whose whole
thing is like
this is what I want this is what I want
to believe my life to be so I'm gonna
believe that my life is that it kind of
helped inform me as in like a really
like backdoor type of way that I didn't
expect
um yeah
that makes so much sense how about for
you Ryan I knew a new tool in your
directing toolkit maybe that now you can
take on to Future films yeah so sorry
the question was about sort of the
Restriction of covid and how that makes
you
of what that teaches you about and
discover new corners of your craft that
you wouldn't have been able to with all
the typical resources yeah I think I
mean a big thing for me is I love crew
and I and I always
value everybody on set and I think I
actually kind of want to like big up the
covid like specific people
um you know every morning
putting like
cotton buds up people's noses it's like
and being really nice and really
respectful and kind about all of that
and having to go up to people constantly
you know on set and saying sorry would
you mind like stepping for you know like
that job I just respected it so much and
and um it really it weirdly that
specific role I've got a lot of respect
for but it also made me just love crew
even more
um because it's not easy and and it's a
it's intense you know it's a lot it's
long days and it's just hard
um but yeah so I I guess it almost like
just re-emphasized how much I love
working with the crew yeah and shout out
to that was Mel Mel Melissa yeah
Mel would like you know just about
enough what rain said it we were like it
was it's actually compliments rain again
like we were like a proper family like
so it meant that no matter what we were
going through it was just like coming on
set making it work and like you know
it was it was unlike anything else like
I've been on to have that family during
covert especially when people just want
to like you know go home or go out or do
something else we were like no we want
to come to sex
it was it was it was a special time like
what six weeks so insane amazing
everyone has their own unique approach
to making films but I'm just a big
believer that a company should feel like
a family like whether whether it's
because of challenges uh involving covet
or not making a movie is a really
challenging like miracle and if you're
gonna go through all that you better
have a supportive family around you and
not just colleagues in my opinion at
least yeah it's key it's just like be
kind and I think everybody on that
that's a big thing for me it's like I
have to work with kind people people can
be difficult sometimes or hard or very
opinionated but if they're kind they're
good like and that was the really nice
thing about
um Riley and it's everybody on that was
is was kind is kind and where when
you're kind and supportive you can
overcome challenges so can you each name
a day on set when something wasn't going
to plan you found a creative pivot you
found some magic that you wouldn't have
otherwise and a scene is better off for
it rain why are you laughing
I know I know I know them I think but
anyway
know I mean I don't know every day was
peachy
um
he's
[Music]
no do you know what we okay look we we
had some a couple challenging days and
it could be miscommunications and like
time is like you just said
um making a film is uh a miracle you
know I mean there's so much that goes
into it so time restriction is coming to
play like the producers on on Reigns
back and Reigns trying not to let us
know that they're on their back and
we've got to shoot like a very emotional
scene where we're like screaming at each
other in 12 minutes
um you know I'm gonna generally say
those those days were everything is hard
because I think as well so because it's
everyone's first Everyone Cared so so so
much so everyone and everyone is so
meticulous about like what they do and
so like it takes time to put like Olan
calandri the um cinematographers just
the dop he is just so so so amazing but
like the detail that goes into every
single shot rain asks like everyone you
know so I think that then adds up and
then suddenly you have two minutes left
like to shoot like a mad scene but yeah
it's like again without the familial
Dynamic we wouldn't have been able to
kind of overcome that but it kind of
when you have a little bit of a
frustration from elsewhere you can plug
it into the scene and then it works so
also like it's like you know it goes
without saying like this is this is like
this is an indie film you know so like
like not like it felt to me like
yeah it's just a miracle us making this
how it how it was and that rain like
really putting her foot down and having
like a detailed Vision but and they put
like us not having time but she's
somehow fun finding time and
communicating it to us communicating it
to Ola and communicating it to Anna a
wonderful um and a rose our wonderful
production designer like you know it was
it was now I'm thinking about it was
tough but she was we were like
having the best time yeah time I agree I
think time is the the hardest thing and
it's also again like as a director you
have to respect everybody's craft so the
cinematographer needs time to light the
art Department need to dress the set
costume need time you know makeup need
time everybody needs time to do their
best and then your end you end up going
right we've got five minutes to shoot
the scene that actors need time they
need to be happy with what they've done
you know
um and I need time to to feed into them
and and I think luckily everyone's
really good so they can do it quite
quickly but um yeah they're a few
occasions where I think particularly
where it was just about light you know
everybody has that thing light
um which is the one that I thought maybe
with David specifically because we were
running out of time we were running out
of light and it was a really difficult
scene and you know but um yeah time time
sometimes I play a Would You Rather game
and I'll ask filmmakers would you rather
have more time or more money
more money means more time you cheated
it
makes sense no but more more money
um because I think people should be paid
well to achieve what they want to
achieve and but that means they have
more time sorry so it that's a really
annoying smug answer but yeah it does me
if you find loopholes in my questions I
applaud them I also applaud the three of
you you're exceptional in the film and
how it all comes together really is
something else and it makes it a highly
unique experience congratulations thank
you thank you so much thank you
everybody out there rileen keep an eye
out for it and stay tuned we'll have
more from Sundance 2023 for you soon